[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend das
war ein europäisches treffen heute in
Prag wie man es in der Form noch nicht
gesehen hat 44 europäische Staaten
gemeinsam auf einem Gipfel darunter die
eu-abtrünnigen Briten oder auch Staaten
die schwere Konflikte miteinander haben
wie Aserbaidschan und Armenien oder ein
schwieriges Verhältnis zur EU wie die
Türkei sogar die Schweiz die sonst
neutrale Distanz wart reiste an die
vielleicht wichtigsten Teilnehmer aber
waren die Ukraine Georgien und die
Republik Moldau vor allem ihnen galt die
Solidarität dieses Gipfeltreffens zudem
im Grunde nur zwei Staaten nicht
eingeladen waren die man dem
europäischen Kontinent zu rechnen kann
Russland und Belarus ihr nicht dazu
gehören war die zentrale Aussage dieser
Veranstaltung Andreas Künast berichtet
den Menschen in Prag hat in 100 und vier
Jahren in zwei Weltkriegen und in Zeiten
der Besatzung ein Motto Mut gemacht
bravder Fichte sie die Wahrheit wird
siegen der tschechische Leitspruch weht
über der Prager Burg weht über Europas
mega-gipfel über den heutigen engsten
über dem heutigen Krieg
time es kann sein dass es dauert aber
wir wissen alle in unseren Herzen dass
die Ukraine am Ende siegen wird weil sie
die Wahrheit auf ihrer Seite hat
es hat einen Krieg in Europa gebraucht
um Europa und Nachbarn zusammen zu
trommeln man reibt sich die Augen da ist
Aserbaidschans Präsident aliyef auf
demselben roten Teppich wie sein
Kriegsgegner Armeniens premier pashinian
da muss der türkische Präsident Erdogan
an der finnischen Ministerpräsidentin
Marine vorbei deren NATO-Beitritt er
blockiert da kommt Großbritanniens
überzeugte eu-gegnerin listrash die nun
doch mitreden will auf dem Kontinent es
gibt endlos viele europa-formate aber
keines das so hochkarätig so zwanglos
und so riskant ist
wir würden etwas Falsches machen wenn
wir jetzt neben all die institutionellen
Strukturen noch eine weitere packen
würden es geht darum dass das in einer
guten Regelmäßigkeit stattfindet und dem
Gespräch in Europa dient Gesprächsthema
des Tages ist Olaf Scholz das
Deutschland mit seinem 200 Milliarden
nur seine eigene Wirtschaft seine
eigenen Bürger schützt finden viele in
Prag uneuropäisch the German economy die
deutsche Wirtschaft ist so groß dass die
Hilfe der Bundesregierung den
gemeinsamen Binnenmarkt zerstören könnte
das vor allem die kleinen Staaten dem
großen Deutschland einen Alleingang
vorwerfen ist für seinen immer noch
neuen Kanzler kein unwesentliches
Problem es wird keine deutschen
Alleingänge geben wir werden keine
Alleingänge machen es gibt keine
deutschen Alleingänge es darf keine
deutschen Alleingänge geben deutsche
alleinnengänge wären falsch das Ambiente
ist edel die Kritik an Scholz derb den
Alleingang werfen dem Kanzler neben den
Balken auch Spanien Portugal und wenig
überraschend Polen vor
wir sehen ganz deutlich dass es nicht
sein darf dass die Energiepolitik der EU
von Deutschland diktiert ist
ich finde dass Deutschland jedes Recht
hat diese Entscheidungen zu treffen wie
wir auch und jeder andere
der große Anspruch mit dem sich Europa
in Prag versammelt hat steht schon am
ersten Abend auf dem Prüfstand brav da
Wicht Jessi die Wahrheit wird siegen
ja und dann schalten wir noch zu
ulfrolla nach Prag Ulf ein gemeinsames
Europa weit über die EU hinaus ist denn
da noch mehr drin als Symbolik
also zumindest die 44 Regierungschefs
die heute hier waren glauben daran dass
dieses Format einen gewissen Sinn ergibt
denn es wird ein weiteres Treffen geben
man hält das für wichtig dieses
Familienfoto und die klare Botschaft an
Putin das sein krieg hier absolut
kritisiert und abgelehnt wird allerdings
kann man auf dieses Format eben aus zwei
Blickwinkeln gucken man kann natürlich
ein bisschen salopp sagen außer Spesen
ist nicht wirklich viel gewesen es ist
nichts verabschiedet worden die
Konflikte die es bei diesen 44 Ländern
gibt sind nicht kleiner geworden also
warum dieser Riesenaufwand oder man kann
eben wirklich darauf gucken dass man
sagt trotz dieser unterschiedlichen
Interessen trotz sogar Länder die im
Krieg sind wie Armenien und
Aserbaidschan sitzt man eben zusammen
und versucht diesem Europa XXL eine
kraftvolle Stimme zu geben und viele
glauben dass das wichtig ist weil es auf
der einen Seite die Weltmacht Amerika
gibt und auf der anderen Seite die
Weltmacht China und da muss Europa
aufpassen dass es nicht zerrieben wird
und deshalb glaubt man wohl auch an
dieses Format gibt es einen EU-Europa ja
deutliche Kritik am deutschen
doppelwumms an den 200 Milliarden dass
das haben wir eben gehört was wird
Scholz dazu in der eu-runde morgen noch
zu hören bekommen
ja so jede Kanzlerschaft hat so seine
seine Schlagzeile und das ist jetzt
dieser doppelwumms er ist ja
wahrscheinlich ausgedacht worden um eben
die Deutschen zu beruhigen aber er
beunruhigt hier sehr sehr viel in Europa
gerade die finanziell schwächeren man
hat das Gefühl dass sich Deutschland
sehr breitbeinig in den europäischen
Binnenmarkt aufstellt und eben mit
seiner Finanzkraft sich vielleicht aus
dieser Energiekrise rauskauft was andere
nicht können man konnte sehr deutliche
Worte hören wie das Diktat das haben die
Polen den deutschen vorgeworfen oder
eben auch ein unesolidarisches Verhalten
ich meine Olaf Scholz sagt dass andere
das auch tun und er ist auch verteidigt
worden dass nämlich wenn die deutsche
Wirtschaft wirklich in den Sinkflug geht
das für Europa auch sehr sehr schwierig
ist also morgen wird es viele
Diskussionen geben es wird auch ein
Familienfoto geben aber es wird auch ein
kräftigen Familienkrach geben
Dankeschön Ulf für die Einschätzung nach
Prag
zur irrwitzigen Kriegsstrategie Putins
gehört es ja auch Gebiete zu annektieren
und für Russisch zu erklären die er noch
nicht mal militärisch unter Kontrolle
hat wie die Region saporiscia das
Atomkraftwerk dort ist von russischen
Truppen besetzt die gleichnamige
Großstadt aber ist nach wie vor unter
ukrainischer Kontrolle und meldet heute
schweren Beschuss in der Nacht sein
russische Raketen in Wohnhäusern
eingeschlagen Russland beschießt also
Gebiete die es formell unter seinen
Schutz gestellt hat wie ist in der
annexionserklärung von moskauzynisch
formuliert wurde
der Wahl der Ukrainer weiter Ortschaften
im Süden in der Region hassson und im
Osten zurückerobern bei den Truppen
heute gab es Besuch aus Deutschland
Alisa jung berichtet aus der Ukraine
mirija hieß das größte Flugzeug der Welt
das heißt Traum auf Ukrainisch hier sind
die Reste dieses Traums zerstört beim
Einmarsch der Russen im Februar es ist
die erste Station für die Vorsitzende
des
bundesverteidigungsausschusses Strack
Zimmermann auf ihrer Ukraine Reise die
FDP-Politikerin ist hier um mit Soldaten
zu sprechen sie will wissen wie wirksam
die deutschen Waffen sind und wie nötig
Kampfpanzer der Kommandeur des
Flughafens kämpfte gegen die Russen als
sie auf dem Weg nach Kiew fahren damals
wie heute fordern viele mehr Waffen vor
allem Panzer
leider habe ich bislang noch keine
Leopard-Panzer ausprobieren dürfen ich
hoffe aber bald
wenn wir genug moderne Waffen gehabt
hätten wie Kampfhubschrauber hätten wir
uns viel effektiver verteidigen können
damit sie auch ihren Kampf im Süden an
der Frontlinie erfolgreich fortsetzen
können wie diese Bilder der ukrainischen
Seite nach reson zeigen sollen es geht
weiter in den Norden zur Grenze Richtung
Belarus heute kaum vorstellbar hier
rollte zu Kriegsbeginn der
kilometerlange russische Militärkonvoi
Ziel Kiew hier haben die Ukrainer sie
vertrieben doch die Sorge ist geblieben
wir können die Möglichkeit eines neuen
Angriffs aus der Richtung nicht
ausschließen auch letztes Mal haben
viele nicht geglaubt dass es tatsächlich
ein Angriff geben könnte die Russen
kamen damals über die belarussische
Grenze nur wenige Kilometer von hier
entfernt viele Brücken wurden deshalb
gesprengt
das ist krass sagt Strack Zimmermann bei
diesem Anblick und auch beim nächsten
Stopp ist die deutsche Delegation
zunächst sprachlos auch hier wüteten
russische Truppen in Tschernobyl ein Ort
der doch schon Katastrophe genug ist
erst hier im Norden jetzt im Süden im
Kernkraftwerk in saporisia die Sorge von
nuklearen Angriffen oder einem Unfall
hört nicht auf
aber natürlich bei einem neuen Überfall
einem neuen Angriff wächst die Gefahr
sowohl für die ganze Welt als auch für
die Ukraine
deshalb setzen sie ihre Hoffnung in
Besuche wie diese ob sie etwas
ausrichten können ist fraglich
und Marie Agnes Strack Zimmermann ist
uns aus Kiew zugeschaltet guten Abend
Frau Zimmermann
guten Abend Frau Slomka sie haben sich
heute auch mit ukrainischen Kommandeuren
also mit Vertretern der ukrainischen
Armee unterhalten welchen Eindruck
hatten sie wie dort der Kriegsverlauf
eingeschätzt wird wir bekommen im Moment
ja relativ viele Erfolgsmeldungen für
die Ukrainer hier zu hören
also grundsätzlich ist man guten Mutes
aber man verdeckt auch nicht dass der
Winter vor der Tür steht dass die
Angriffe wieder zunehmen und dass man
natürlich sich Gedanken macht wie man
eben in den nächsten Monaten weiter so
gefechtsbereit sein kann und insofern
ist man das muss man an der Stelle sagen
in deutschen sehr sehr dankbar das was
wir liefern wenn auch ein bisschen
später dass das exzellentes Material ist
da ist man uns dankbar in jeder Hinsicht
aber man hofft natürlich dass es
weiterhin Lieferungen gibt gerade was
Munition betrifft und eben auch anderes
Gerät mit anderes Gerät meinen sie
Schützenpanzer und Kampfpanzer wie den
Leo
ja das ist natürlich hier auch ein Thema
es ist nicht nur ein Thema also das
Thema Munition und generell Nachschub
ist ein großes ABER man wünscht sich
eben auch was weil die Ukraine eine
Menge ihrer eigenen Panzer inzwischen
verloren hat eben ein am liebsten den
Leopard 2 das muss man sagen den
Kampfpanzer nicht nur weil er die
eigenen Panzer ersetzt sondern weil er
von seiner Feuerkraft von seiner
Qualität eine völlig andere Situation
her macht und es geht eben darum
russische Stellungen bekämpfen zu können
an manchen Stellen wir waren heute im
Norden des Landes haben sich die Russen
zurückgezogen weil man eben unter
anderem auch deren nachschubversorgung
zerstört hat also Brücken zerstört hat
und insofern dort nachzurücken wäre eben
ein wichtiges Moment damit der Angriff
nicht erneut stattfinden kann das Wissen
dass diese Botschaft bitte Kampfpanzer
aus Deutschland vom Bundeskanzler nicht
gern gehört wird und vermutlich vor
allem dann nicht gerne gehört wird wenn
er aus den eigenen Reihen der eigenen
Ampelkoalition kommt
na ja gut das Thema ist ja ich darf das
so sagen so alt wie dieser Krieg es ist
ja kein neues Thema das ist ja
mittengrund warum ich auch hierher
gefahren bin um eben mal vor Ort mit
Soldaten eben auch in entsprechenden
Situationen ins Gespräch zu kommen und
wie gesagt da ist der Dank aber da ist
auch der Wunsch und ich glaube dass wir
darüber in Deutschland auch weiter
sprechen sollten ja wir sind eine Ampel
ja wir sind eine Regierung aber egal
welche Regierung es gewesen wäre vor
Slomka diese Diskussion hätten wir
geführt die müssen wir auch in Zukunft
führen denn in dieser Krieg und der
Ausgang dieses Krieges kann und wird uns
nicht egal sein und wenn wir unseren
Teil dazu beitragen können dann wäre das
von großer Bedeutung aber sie möchten
mit dieser Reise schon auch Druck auf
Olaf Scholz ausüben denn die
Konstellation ist ja so dass FDP und
Grüne bereit wären sie müssen es für den
Schützenpanzer und die SPD bzw der
Bundeskanzler das nicht will weil er
eine Eskalation befürchtet das scheint
zumindest die Einschätzung zu sein so
genau wissen wir es ja nicht
nein wir wissen es in der Tat nicht also
ich reise jetzt nicht hierhin um
ausschließlich Druck auf den
Bundeskanzler zu machen das wäre dann
doch etwas zu simpel aber es ist
natürlich allein die Tatsache dass ich
gereist bin wirkt unter Umständen schon
aber es geht mir darum wenn man diese
Diskussion führt dass man sie seriös
führt dass man sie nicht aus dem warmen
Deutschland herausführt sondern eben
sich die Eindrücke auch hier holt und
deswegen bleibt der Wunsch und auch der
Wunsch der Freien Demokraten dass eben
Panzer auch hierher geliefert werden
ich fand es ganz interessant letztens
mal eine Sorge von einem großen zu hören
denn überhaupt kein putinfreund ist
sondern das Land fluchtartig verlassen
musste der sagt dass deutsche Panzer
auch mit dem bundeswehrkreuz drauf die
dann auf russische Stellungen zurollen
dass das Bilder wären die eigentlich
eher die russische Propaganda und das
Putin narrativ jetzt seht wir kämpfen
gegen die Deutschen wir kämpfen gegen
Nazis sogar befeuern könnte das sind
Gedanke der sich auch mal zu Ende zu
denken lohnt dass das ein Grund sein
Können zu sagen da sind wir dann doch
vielleicht eher vorsichtig
also es ist möglich dass man so denkt es
ist auch möglich dass man so im
Bundeskanzleramt denkt aber wir sollten
diesem narrativ der Russen auch nicht
zum Opfer fallen ich weiß von den
Ukrainer hier im Land dass das für sie
keine Rolle spielt gerade die Ukraine
die er unter den Nazis besonders
gelitten hat sondern sie sehen den
Leopard als Kampfmittel und dass er in
Deutschland hergestellt wird und ein
deutsches Produkt ist es das eine es
geht ihnen aber eben die eigenen
Soldaten auch in einer gewissen
Sicherheit kämpfen zu lassen und
insofern wäre es glaube ich fatal wenn
wir diesem narrativ Glauben schenken
oder diesen nachlaufen sollten sondern
wir sollten das tun was zu tun ist und
es geht jetzt darum dass natürlich
parallel zur Artillerie das muss man
auch sagen die hier dringend gebraucht
wird die sehr sehr wirksam ist sei es
der Geppert sei es die Panzerhaubitze
sei es das Maß 2 dass man eben
zusätzlich will man Stellungen der
Russen bekämpfen eben auch Panzer
braucht weil wie gesagt die die Ukraine
bisher hatte Stück für Stück Ausfall das
alte sowjetisches Material und ich im
entferntesten die Qualität die man ein
deutscher Panzer zu bieten hat sagt die
Vorsitzende des Verteidigungsausschusses
des Deutschen Bundestags vielen Mann für
das Gespräch
danke Ihnen Frau Slomka
das Interview haben wir vor zwei Stunden
aufgezeichnet und mit dem
Kriegsgeschehen in der Ukraine geht es
jetzt auch bei dir erst noch mal weiter
eins ja der Chef der Internationalen
Atomenergiebehörde grossy hat erneut
eine Sicherheitszone um das von Russland
besetzte Atomkraftwerk saporicia
gefordert große reiste heute nach Kiew
und kündigte nach einem Gespräch mit
Präsident selenski an dass er bald auch
in Moskau hochrangige Gespräche führen
werde es gehe vor allem darum einen
nuklear-unfall zu verhindern
auf dem deutschen Pflegetag beraten
heute und morgen Vertreter aus dem Beruf
aus Politik Wirtschaft und Verbänden
über den Stand der Pflege in Deutschland
zum Auftakt forderte
pflegeratspräsidentin Vogler
grundlegende Reformen und warnte ohne
die benötigte Unterstützung durch die
Politik werde pflegerische Versorgung in
Zukunft nicht mehr ausreichend
stattfinden
Bundesgesundheitsminister Lauterbach
bezeichnete dem Beruf als zentrale Säule
und räumte ein die Arbeitsbedingungen in
der Pflege seien massiv
verbesserungsbedürftig
im Norden Thailands hat ein ehemaliger
Polizist in einer Kindertagesstätte mehr
als 30 Menschen getötet überwiegend
Kinder der Mann schoss nach
Polizeiangaben in der Einrichtung um
sich und flüchtete danach vom Tatort
später fuhr er nach Hause und tötete
dort seine Frau sein Kind und sich
selbst die Hintergründe des Angriffs
sind noch unklar der mutmaßliche Täter
soll vor kurzem wegen Drogendelikten aus
dem Polizeidienst entlassen worden sein
der frühere Freiburger Erzbischof und
Vorsitzende der Deutschen
Bischofskonferenz Zollitsch hat
Missbrauchsopfer um Entschuldigung
gebeten und eigene Fehler eingeräumt in
einer Videobotschaft sagte Zollitsch er
habe es versäumt Missbrauchsfälle
offenzulegen und stattdessen Vorwürfe
intern behandelt sein Verhalten habe den
Opfern zusätzliches Leid bereitet
nach der Beschädigung eines Fensters
einer Synagoge der jüdischen Gemeinde
Hannover gestern Abend hat der
Staatsschutz die Ermittlungen übernommen
eine antisemitische Straftat können
nicht ausgeschlossen werden bisher gibt
es aber keine Angaben zu möglichen
Tätern einem Motiv oder dem Tathergang
auch wie die Scheibe zerstört wurde ist
noch unbekannt in der Synagoge hat mehr
als 150 Menschen den Abschluss des
höchsten jüdischen Feiertags
bei dem nicht sonderlich Ergebnis
reichen Bund Länder treffen am Dienstag
hätte einer vermutlich besonders gern
etwas mehr nach Hause gebracht der Wahl
kämpfende Ministerpräsident Stefan weil
am Sonntag wird in Niedersachsen gewählt
fürs ZDF hat die Forschungsgruppe Wahlen
ein Politbarometer extra erstellt wie
immer sind solche Umfragen nur
Momentaufnahmen keine Prognosen aber
doch interessant
demnach käme wenn heute schon gewählt
würde die SPD auf 33 Prozent die derzeit
noch mit regierende CDU auf 28 die
Grünen landeten bei 16 Prozent die FDP
muss mit fünf Prozent um ihren
Wiedereinzug in den Landtag bangen
anders als die AFD die mit zehn Prozent
sogar zweistellig würde die Linke
wiederum würde den Einzug ins Parlament
erneut verpassen
man könnte es am Sonntag also einige
lange Gesichter geben und eventuell
einen Koalitionswechsel über den
Wahlkampf Endspurt berichtet Peter Kunz
sich rüsten in unsicherer Zeit
spd-ministerpräsident Stefan weil der
sein Amt verteidigen will auf dem
gepanzerten Fahrzeug CDU Herausforderer
Bernd Althusmann vor dem Marder so viel
Wehrhaftigkeit auf Bildern im Wahlkampf
das gab es in Deutschland lange nicht
Niedersachsen bleibt der größte
Bundeswehrstandort aber die hilft nicht
beim Frontalangriff auf die etablierte
Politik mit Videos die radikale Gruppen
ins Netz stellen und vielen störattacken
bei den Auftritten der Parteien im
Bundesland
[Applaus]
in dieser krisenwelt wird bei den Wahlen
am Sonntag laut letzter zahlen die
niedersächsische AFD massiv profitieren
interner Streit auch
staatsanwaltschaftliche Ermittlungen das
perlt offenbar ab wir nähern uns den
Wahlziel an was ich immer ausgegeben
habe 12% + X das habe ich damals
ausgegeben weil ich die Stimmung unter
der Bevölkerung kenne andere stehen früh
auf um die Temperatur beim Wähler zu
fühlen
Ministerpräsident Stefan weil liegt mit
seiner SPD und dem Landesvater Bonus
inzwischen klar vor der CDU die Wähler
sprechen ihm auch mehr
Wirtschaftskompetenz zu
je schneller für Bürgerinnen und Bürger
klar ist dass sie sich keine Angst
machen müssen wir schneller auch
konkrete Entlastung spürbar sind desto
schneller bin ich überzeugt werden wir
auch wieder mehr Vertrauen haben
deswegen ist das jetzt eine für alle
Beteiligten wirklich belastende
Zwischenzeit belastende Zwischenzeit für
weil am Ende des Wahlkampfes nach einer
wenig ergiebigen
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz vorgestern
steht für die Ampel in Berlin noch eine
Zeitenwende durch Ergebnisse aus
jeder Bürger der jetzt darüber nachdenkt
gebe ich Stefan weil meine Stimme der
muss mit einkalkulieren dass er dann
eine rot-grüne Regierung bekommt oder
eine kleine Ampel landesampel das sollte
sicherlich sehr gut überdacht werden ob
wir dieses Theater was wir auf
Bundesebene erleben kein Tag ohne Streit
dass wir das in Niedersachsen dann am
Ende auch haben werden mobilisieren
gegen Rot-Grün die CDU könnte sich auch
eine neue große Koalition in
Niedersachsen vorstellen diesmal unter
ihrer Führung dazu müssten die Ärzte
Demokraten aber erst auf dann überholen
Rot-Grün scheint gesetzt trotz Berliner
Irrungen und Wirrungen
machen und dazu stehen und diese zu
korrigieren und genau das lebt Robert
Habeck gerade auf Bundesebene und auch
das ist ein grüner Politikstil der
Politikstil der FDP allerdings könnte in
Niedersachsen auf der Strecke bleiben
ihr Wiedereinzug in den Landtag auf der
Kippe unser Herzblut für Niedersachsen
das ist das Plakat beim Fall unter fünf
Prozent aber würde der Partei nicht nur
hier in Hannover das Herz bluten
und das Politbarometer extra zionell der
sachsenwahl können Sie bei uns auch noch
mal online abrufen auf ZDF heute und
nochmals mit dem Blick auf die
Wirtschaft die deutsche Industrie hat im
August einen Rückgang bei den Aufträgen
verbucht das meldet der Statistische
Bundesamt sowohl im Inland als auch im
Ausland gegen die Nachfrage nach
deutschen waren zurück Frank Bethmann
wie sind die Erwartungen wie es für die
deutsche Industrie weitergeht man muss
kein Prophet sein die heimische
Industrie steht vor schwierigen Monaten
vor allem kommen offenbar keine
Großaufträge mehr rein das neue Geschäft
geht um 2,4 Prozent zurück der
kräftigste Rückgang seit dem
Kriegsausbruch auf den ersten Blick halb
so schlimm die Industrie ist weiter kaum
in der Lage Aufträge abzuarbeiten weil
es Alexander Krüger vom Bankhaus Hauck
auf Häuser Lampe wohl auch deshalb
halten sich die Unternehmen mit neuen
Aufträgen zurück es sind aber auch die
hohen Energiekosten die viele
Anschaffungen inzwischen in Frage
stellen
machen zunehmend mehr Kunden einen
Rückzieher als erstes beginnen dass die
deutschen Autobauer zu spüren nach dem
Motto alles wird teurer vielleicht
sparen wir uns dann den neuen Wagen
lieber es ist so dass wir erste
Stornierungen sehen bestätigt Antje
Woltermann vom Zentralverband deutsches
Kfz-Gewerbe wir hören seit mehr als vier
Wochen aus dem Handel dass die Kunden
zurückhaltender werden und das nicht nur
in der Automobilindustrie die dicken
Auftragspolster also trügerisch es droht
ein schwieriges Winterhalbjahr Frank
Bethmann vielen Dank
und die Bundesnetzagentur warnt vor
einem weiterhin zu hohen Gasverbrauch
ihr Präsident Klaus Müller sagte ohne
Einsparungen von mindestens 20 Prozent
werde sich eine gasnotlage im Winter
kaum vermeiden lassen nach Zahlen seiner
Behörde lag der Gasverbrauch der
privaten Haushalte und kleinere Gewerbe
allein in der letzten Woche fast zehn
Prozent über dem durchschnittlichen
Verbrauchsniveau der vergangenen Jahre
ein Ergebnisse aus der fußball-europa
liegt vom Abend Union Berlin hat
auswärts beim schwedischen Vertreter
Malmö gewonnen mit 1:0 überschattet
wurde das Spiel von mutmaßlichen
Fan-Ausschreitungen mit
Feuerwerkskörpern die zu einer rund
25-minütigen Unterbrechung führten
zum Auftakt der judoweltmeisterschaften
in Usbekistan hat Katharina Menz aus
Backnang Silber gewonnen Gold in der
Gewichtsklasse bis 48 Kilogramm ging an
die Titelverteidigerin dazu mit zu Notar
aus Japan
der Europäische Gerichtshof hat die
Rechte von Passagieren bei Verspätungen
von Anschlussflügen gestärkt fluggäste
können auch dann eine Entschädigung
fordern wenn eine Reise aus mehreren
Flügen besteht und diese von
unterschiedlichen Airlines durchgeführt
werden urteilte die Richter
voraussetzung sei allerdings dass die
Flüge gemeinsam auf einem Ticket gebucht
wurden
der ganztägige Pilotenstreik bei
Eurowings Deutschland hat heute zu
zahlreichen Flugausfällen geführt etwa
die Hälfte der Eurowings Flotte blieb am
Boden 250 von 500 Verbindungen wurden
gestrichen vor allem in Düsseldorf Köln
Hamburg Stuttgart und Berlin knapp
30.000 Passagiere sind betroffen die
Pilotengewerkschaft Cockpit fordert
bessere Arbeitsbedingungen etwa kürzere
Einsatzzeiten
Literatur Nobelpreis ist ja immer eine
spannende Angelegenheit mal sind die
Preisträger umstritten mal müssen selbst
kulturredakteure erstmal googeln wer das
überhaupt ist manchmal wird aber auch
jemand gekürt dem in der Literaturwelt
viele die Daumen drückten so wie dieses
Jahr anni Erno ist eine der größten
französischen Schriftstellerinnen der
Gegenwart oder wie der Kollege Nils
minkma von der Süddeutschen Zeitung
schon im Mai prophetisch schrieb
verdient hat sie ihn und in Paris sind
sich viele sicher dass es klappt weil es
klappen muss und das hat geklappt unser
Frankreich Korrespondent Thomas Walde
stellt uns die frisch gekürte
Nobelpreisträgerin vor
im Haus Ihres Verlages in Paris reagiert
anni Erno auf den Preis den Sie gerade
verliehen bekommen hat
den nobel zu erhalten ist für mich eine
Verantwortung weiterzumachen
offen zu sein nicht nur für die
Frauenfrage sondern auch allgemein das
Voranschreiten der Welt und den Wunsch
nach Frieden
zuvor hat das Nobelkomitee seine
Entscheidung in einer Tonlage begründet
die zur Preisträgerin passt
zurückhaltend und präzise vor der
curridge für den Mut und die klinische
Schärfe mit der sie die Wurzeln
Entfremdungen und kollektiven
Beschränkungen der persönlichen
Erinnerung aufdeckt
Erno schreibt mit autobiografischen
Bezügen authentisch ohne Angst vom
Standpunkt einer Frau etwa über eine
traumatische Abtreibung über Affären mit
einem russischen Diplomaten oder einem
jungen Mann
das ist eine so tolle Frau und eine
Literatur die mir sehr gefällt trotz
ihres Alters ist sie ungemein modern
ich bewundere ihre Arbeit Feminismus
Jugend die Sache der Frauen sie ist eine
inspirierende Autoren
[Musik]
die Bücher sind für junge Menschen
leicht zugänglich sie sprechen Frauen
und vor allem Mädchen sehr an
vor der letzten Präsidentschaftswahl
forderte er nur dazu auf die linke zu
wählen gleichwohl würdigte Präsident
macron heute ihr Schaffen ihre Stimme
ist die Stimme der Freiheit der Frauen
und der vergessenen des Jahrhunderts an
einem Tag der großen Worte hat die
Preisträgerin dann das letzte Wort es
ist eines der Bescheidenheit
ich werde so leben wie ich mir das
vorher gedacht hatte das wird mein
alltägliches Leben nicht verändern
für ihren Verlag ändert sich dagegen
einiges seit der Bekanntgabe des Preises
gehen bei ihm zahlreiche Bestellungen
der Werke Eros ein
das war es von uns gleich nach dem
Wetter geht es weiter bei Maybrit Illner
die mit ihren Gästen über den 200
Milliarden doppelwumms debattiert wird
es damit gelingen die Krise auszubremsen
und um 0.30 gibt es dann unsere
heute-update mit Nathan göktem hier
wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend die Tage werden kürzer die
Temperaturen sinken Zugvögel beginnen
ihre Reise nach Süden dabei nutzen zum
Beispiel Kraniche aus Skandinavien
Mitteleuropa und den baltischen Staaten
den westeuropäischen Zugweg er führt
über Deutschland zu den Winterquartieren
im milden Südfrankreich und in Spanien
dass sich das klimawandelt merken auch
die Tiere so verkürzen Zugvögel ihre
Reise oder überwintern gleich in der
Nähe der Brutgebiete und Balken sich um
Nahrung mit den Vögeln die noch nie
weggezogen sind wenn Sie also Kraniche
hier im Winter beobachten ist das ein
Zeichen des Klimawandels
und damit zurück zu unserem goldenen
Oktoberwetter das heute mal kurz gestört
wurde durch eine kleine Kaltfront die
heute Mittag 22 Grad in Südostbayern von
16 Grad weiter im Norden trennte die
kalt von da reicht jetzt in der Nacht
den Alpenrand in Süddeutschland bildet
sich dicker Nebel im Norden ist es
dagegen klar so sinken die Temperaturen
unter klarem Himmel zum Teil auf zwei
bis null Grad dann droht Bodenfrost
milder bleibt die Nacht im Norden und im
Süden und morgen wird es mit mit
Höchsttemperaturen von 17 bis 22 Grad
der Nebel hält sich in den Flusstälern
Süddeutschlands zäh wenn sich der Nebel
auflöst strahlt auch dort die Sonne
genauso wie in Norddeutschland erst am
Nachmittag kann es dann einzelne
Regenschauer hier in Schleswig-Holstein
geben am Samstag gibt es neue Schauer
und Gewitter vor allen Dingen Nordwesten
am freundlichsten wird zwischen der
Ostseeküste und dem Oberrhein der
Sonntag bringt dann schon wieder
goldenes Oktoberwetter am Montag wird es
von Westen wechselhafter guten Abend